[Música]
todos los días
yo tengo dos tres y hasta cinco
reuniones con las personas de los
ámbitos más diversos
jueces narcotraficantes políticos
empresarios
y la chismosa de tu barrio
si la chismosa de tu barrio habla
conmigo
ese es mi trabajo porque yo busco
información pero una información muy
específica que es sobre los delincuentes
de cuello blanco los expertos en la
corrupción el lavado el narcotráfico el
fraude corporativo los llamados
delincuentes de cuello blanco que se
visten así
no se visten como la serie de televisión
todos los días por esto me tengo que
reunir además y hablo con mis editores
porque tenemos que cruzar información y
tratar de separar lo que son datos de
versiones y esto es bastante más difícil
de lo que parece porque les garantizo
que la realidad en este país supera la
ficción
solo en esta vida paralela es que por
ejemplo es posible que uno de los más
grandes operadores judiciales de los
últimos 25 años reciba a sus invitados
sea para hablar de un gobierno o de otro
en el quincho de su casa rodeado de dos
pósters una caja de vidrio
y un persuasor
poster número 1
al pacino en cara cortada
poster número 2
marlon brando en el padrino
caja de vidrio con un teléfono celular
dorado recuerdan los viejitos los
zapatos
que cuando le preguntas te dice ese era
el teléfono celular que yo solo usaba
con el número uno
el día que el número uno murió
decidí que este teléfono no se podía
volver a tocar
y el persuasor es un bate de aluminio de
un metro veinte que él mismo aclara que
es para que si alguno de sus invitados
se desubica
y ponerlo en orden
este señor es apenas uno de los que se
mueven por los sótanos de la argentina
en estos sótanos de donde yo trabajo
en estos sótanos de hecho aclaró que
este hombre no es ni siquiera de los más
bravos pero en estos sótanos se definen
algunos de los asuntos más graves y
sensibles de la vida institucional de la
argentina de los últimos 25 o 30 años
y es allí en lugares como este donde se
guardan algunos de los secretos más
incómodos del poder
les voy a contar uno
en la argentina si vos vos vos vos
cualquiera quiere competir por la
presidencia va a necesitar 100 millones
de dólares
repito la cifra si son 100 millones de
dólares cuando se es muchísimo si
quieres competir para intendente
de escobar o de la plata necesitas entre
500 mil dólares y un millón
en algunas ciudades el comprar tu puesto
para el tercer lugar en la lista de
concejales de una ciudad mediana cuesta
100 mil dólares
y aclaro algo esto lo saben todos esto
no es algo que es muy difícil de
conseguir lo saben los políticos lo
saben los empresarios lo saben los
narcos lo saben todos
de hecho como lo saben también los
organismos de control que deberían
controlar por eso el año que viene nos
vamos a encargar una campaña
presidencial
salvo que o la economía o alguna reforma
legislativa de último momento o que las
investigaciones judiciales que ahora
tenemos en marcha modifiquen esto todo
aquel que quiera competir por la
presidencia llegar a la casa rosada
necesita 100 millones de dólares por eso
es que solemos definir al financiamiento
electoral como el pecado original de la
política arrancaste pecando
vos podés tener muy buenas intenciones
grandes ideas
los pies los vas a tener que llenar de
barro
qué significa esto en la práctica que
por arriba de la superficie puedes tener
candidatos que compiten entre sí debaten
y por debajo de la superficie puedes
tener que un candidato financie la
campaña de otro porque le muerde votos a
su principal contendiente y este que no
es estúpido a su vez financia la campaña
de otro para morderle votos a su
principal rival
del mismo modo que otra verdad incómoda'
del poder
es que como se necesitan fortunas y
fortunas que a su vez si cumplir con la
legislación vigente no poder recaudar
esos 100 millones de dólares tenés que
pedir que la inmensa mayoría del dinero
se calcula que el 90 por ciento sean
negro
esto que lleva a su vez que necesitas
casa y necesitas valijeros
del otro lado
quienes son los que ponen el dinero
primero empresarios algunos de los
grandes empresarios que ahora estamos
viendo de fila por tribunales y muchos
de ellos aclaró cómo nos pueden sacar
fondos de sus balances lo que hacen es
ofrecer pago en especie que significa
estos jóvenes y pedís 500 mil dólares no
te puedo dar tengo una fábrica de
empanadas te ofrezco yo te doy las
empanadas para todos los actos de
campaña en todos los lugares donde yo
tengo una sucursal el que tiene o
fabrica autos de entrega autos el que
fabrica o distribuye celulares te
entrega los teléfonos celulares para tu
campaña
esto es una realidad
de los sótanos
ustedes me pueden estar diciendo bueno y
en qué se gastan estos por ejemplo 100
millones de dólares y por otro lado
estos son los únicos no porque tienes
empresarios
que apuestan por los candidatos como si
fueran caballos de carrera apuesta por
el primero pero al mismo tiempo por el
segundo y por la duda que salte la banca
también por el tercero
y no solamente los empresarios la
policía por ejemplo muchas veces
preparan bolsos de la recaudación ilegal
y los entrega para que para generar un
compromiso de ida y vuelta ahora yo sé
que vos sabes y es mutuo y los narcos
cada elección están llegando más lejos y
más alto
y ponerlo de los gastos
estos son los grandes rubros cuando
hablamos nosotros con los equipos de
campaña fuera de micrófono y hablamos en
serio
el primero
la impresión de boletas electorales y
los fiscales el segundo los periodistas
y los medios comunicación rubro 1
en el mundo se calcula que no necesitas
1.3
repito 1.3 boletas electorales por
persona en la argentina
5 porque te la roban
con una combinación adicional si te roba
la boleta va a tener que estar
preparando todos los fiscales y decir
bueno puede ser tanto dinero sea más un
voluntario si será un voluntario por lo
tiene que capacitar lo tiene que llevar
el centro de votación tienen que tener
un jefe superior que tiene que tener
teléfono celular le tiene que dar una
vianda y lo tenés que traer de vuelta
multiplican esto por 95 mil mesas
electorales que son las que tuvimos en
2015 van a ser más ahora en 2019
y por el otro lado medios de
comunicación y periodistas este es uno
de los rubros más caros a ustedes no les
sorprende cuán difícil es a veces es
hablar con un candidato y no lo consigue
nadie no lo consigue nada y cuando
finalmente ese candidato acepta hablar
en una entrevista periodística la
pregunta más difícil que le hacen es
hace calor en jujuy
la entrevista más cara de 2015 costó 42
mil dólares dicho por ellos sí por los
equipos de campaña
ahora me centra en financiamiento
electoral y estos son los usos y
costumbres de los sótanos de este sector
que a su vez esto está dentro de un
entramado que incluye mucho más porque
también incluye por ejemplo a los
policías que mencioné antes con un dato
adicional hay muchas comisarías que se
licitan se subastan se rematan se la
queda el comisario que ofrezca más
dinero entonces yo ofrezco por tal
comisaría pagar 100 mil dólares por mes
entonces si aceptan mi oferta yo sube
después tengo que salir a recaudar
dinero
a como de lugar
de donde como
estos son los policías y aclaro en cada
uno de los rubros hay muchísimas y muy
honrosas
salvedades y no hay que generalizar lo
que estoy contando es como es un
entramado del mismo modo hay muchos
periodistas que no informan cobran por
su silencio hay fiscales que no
investigan cajonean expedientes hay
jueces que se encargan de prescribir los
expedientes empresarios que no compiten
se caracterizan sindicalistas algunos
que defienden a los trabajadores y
muchos otros que entienden clarísimo la
premisa básica que no hay mejor huelga
que aquella que no se hace pero te
permite negociar
por eso si tenemos un entramado de este
tipo que es donde nosotros este es
nuestro trabajo y hablo de mí y de
muchos otros colegas si este es el
entramado que tenemos
es un error quedarse solamente en los
personajes propios de película de clase
de hombre que revolean voley bolso de
dinero un convento o que andan manejando
ferraris objetos hombres son en realidad
muchas veces solo la punta de un iceberg
que es mucho más profundo y que incluye
a lo que nosotros denominamos el poder
permanente le voy a dar una anécdota
sobre esto una vez hablando con un
veterano ex secretario de finanzas me
contaba que en su primera semana en el
ministerio de economía no sabía ni
manejar la botonera del teléfono
entonces recibe a los banqueros se tuvo
que levantar le pedirá la secretaria la
secretaria por favor convoque al mosso
bien hermoso hermoso le dice que se va a
servir le hice un té con limón se dio
vuelta miró a los banqueros y le dice lo
de siempre no
quien está de paso tiene permanente
ahora esto es algo propio solo de la
argentina
y de hecho allí tenemos los casos de
perú de italia de brasil en las últimas
décadas que además nos muestran que
tuvieron problemas de corrupción sistema
o mega corrupción o corrupción
estructural son como se la suele
denominar y también tuvieron después los
problemas posteriores cual es que por
ejemplo en italia tenían la
tangentópolis que se investigó con el
manipule y 'the y terminaron con un
premier italiano correteando menores de
edad por una finca romana o terminamos
ahora en brasil después de la barato con
un presidente electo de extrema derecha
defensor de la dictadura xenófobo y
racista
y este es uno de los riesgos que tenemos
nosotros aquí en la argentina salir de
un problema para terminar en un
problemón
este es un riesgo el otro
es caer en el gatopardismo
qué significa esto simular cambios que
no ocurren y esto es una dicotomía entre
lo que es la argentina real y la
argentina teórica en la argentina
teórica tenemos una oficina
anticorrupción en la argentina real
ahora cambio pero en argentina real
la oficina de corrupción tiene dos sedes
una de las dos sedes no tenía internet
se colgaba del wifi del bar de la
esquina
el día del gastronómico cerraba el bar
no tenían wifi no había internet todos
ustedes con los teléfonos solo les
tienen más capacidad de búsqueda que
toda esa oficina toda esa área de la
oficina anticorrupción ejemplo 1 ejemplo
la justicia electoral los encargados de
controlar todos los verdaderos gastos e
ingresos de todo candidato electoral
tiene un llamado cuerpo nacional de
auditores son los encargados de
controlar todos los ingresos todos los
gastos de todos los candidatos de todos
los partidos en todos los ciclos
electorales de cada dos años saben
cuántos son y aclaro son muy buenos
saben cuántos son
tuvieron que por expediente
administrativo pedir una fotocopiadora
una sola vez le voy a contar alguna
intimidad papá me vino bien una charla
termino y me dijo mi hijito lo tuyo es
brillante pero depresivo
trata de subirlo un poco porque para
agarrarse ledo con la puerta a más la
presión es esta
por lo tanto respetando la promesa que
le hice a mi padre les cuento es posible
corregir esto si es difícil mucho
y en realidad abrevó de lo que ya han
aprendido otros como el gran
investigador de la investigación
italiana el mani pulite antonio di
pietro que parece una idea del coraje
que tuvo se tuvo que ir a vivir a otro
país marco canalé era su nombre falso
meta que le buscaban para matarlo él y
otros como él cuentan que el momento
clave el punto de inflexión es cuando
los ciudadanos se involucran y empiezan
a ejercer presión meten presión él lo
que cuenta es solo puede cambiar cuando
los italianos dijeron basta
y esto es posible si nosotros lo hacemos
y metemos presión podemos lograr la
reforma electoral que imponga la boleta
única terminamos en el robo de boletas o
sacar a la oficina anticorrupción del
orbital poder ejecutivo y muchos otros
ejemplos muchísimos de hecho nosotros lo
hemos tenido en la argentina infinidad
de veces la marcha del silencio en
catamarca para que exigir que se
resolviera el homicidio de la chiquita
morales o el dos por uno cuando hubo un
fallo de la corte y se movilizó la
ciudadanía o la 125 elijan ustedes el
debate por la legalización del aborto
que los legisladores no iban a los
debates y de repente vieron que la
ciudadanía si estaba involucrado en algo
que ellos no y a favor o en contra pero
tuvieron que ponerse los pantalones
entonces si es posible
pero depende de nosotros
[Música]
porque va a depender de nosotros y va a
depender meter mucha presión
es que es clave el esfuerzo cotidiano y
hasta que eso no ocurra yo y otros como
yo nos moveremos por el sótano
hablando con los tony montana y los vito
corleone y esquivando los bates de
aluminio
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah